[Musique]
on va parler de santé avec le professeur
dit la vie un âne qui est chef du
service de réanimation de l'hôpital
raymond poincaré à garches quitte le
doyen de l'ufr santé si bonne nouvelle
d'une université de versailles saint
quentin bonjour professeurs et bonne
année bonjour alors on va évoquer
évidemment le problème de la santé et le
premier problème c'est en effet le
problème du virus avec sow mikron qui a
qui a marqué le début de l'année 2022
qui se répand très vite qui peut-être
moins virulent que ses prédécesseurs
est ce que on a l'impression qu'on
laisse faire finalement et peut-être
pour aller vers une immunité collective
est ce que c'est ça un peu le calcul
qu'on pourrait avoir
alors c'est intéressant ce qu'on reparle
à nouveau dignité collective puisque il
ya quelques semaines quelques mois on
expliqué on deux n'atteindrait jamais
justement tu fais des variants du fait
de la difficulté à déployer la
vaccination sur
l'ensemble de la planète
et donc cette notion même dignité
collective était profondément remise en
cause il y a quelques semaines à peine
ça veut dire quoi l'immunité collective
ça veut dire que l'individu qui n'a ni
fait la maladie ni étaient vaccinés
serait protégé par le groupe qui lui
aurait été vaccinés ou ayant fait la
maladie
dans la réalité comme la vaccination
malheureusement n'empêche pas la
transmission du virus bien c'est un
facteur voiliers qui compromet cette
protection collective et on le vit
aujourd'hui puisque si omicron se
propage aussi vite et de façon aussi
massive alors que 91 % de la population
éligible en france est vaccinée c'est
bien la démonstration même que
malheureusement la vaccination ne permet
pas d'empêcher le virus deux circulait
mais est ce qu'on peut dire quand même
que alors en effet n'empêche pas
viré de circuler mais est ce qu'on peut
dire qu'elle atténue les formes graves
de maladie de façon générale
ça c'est très clairement l'effet
principal de la vaccination dans le
cadre de lakovic 19 un effet remarquable
qui est celui de prévenir les formes
graves et l'évolution vers les formes
graves et je faudrait dire aujourd'hui
heureusement on à 91% de la population
éligible vacciner parce qu'avec le
nombre de contaminations quotidienne
bien on voit qu'on aurait un nombre de
formes graves qui viendraient déborder
de façon massive les hôpitaux et
malheureusement se serait associé à un
nombre de décès considérable on voit les
stic a cité de la vaccination pour nous
protéger des femmes va oui justement ce
ce variant qui est qui ce titre est très
contagieux et n'a pas
immobilisé l'hôpital comme on aurait pu
le craindre un
bain en tout état de cause effectivement
il ne se traduit pas par une
augmentation massive en tout cas pour
l'instant
des hospitalisations en tout cas pas au
delà pas à faire déborder nos hôpitaux
parce que l'attention sur l'hôpital
existe et l'attention sur les services
de réanimation existe aussi la passion
ils sont très nombreux ils arrivent tous
les jours et on est quasiment à
saturation mais honnêtement encore une
fois ça n'est pas grand chose par
rapport à ce qu'on aurait pu attendre
avec le nombre de contaminations
quotidienne il ya plusieurs explications
à la première c'est que il est très
vraisemblable en effet que le variant
omicron soit moins pathogène moins
virulent au sens où il se développerait
davantage au niveau des voies aériennes
supérieures au niveau de la gorge de du
nez de la bouche et atteindre est
beaucoup moins le poumon profond
contraire en pariant delta est donc
engendrant mois de pneumonie et plus
d'infections orl ça c'est une première
explication la deuxième explication qui
est au moins tout aussi importante c'est
que le vario mikron arrive dans une
situation où la vaccination est très
large man déployés et par conséquent les
nous les personnes nous avons une
certaine forme de protection à son égard
et nous ne sommes plus si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi vierge de toute
protection comme c'était le cas dans le
passé et donc c'est sûr c'est la
combinaison de facteurs qui fait que
heureusement omicron ne se traduit pas
par une tension excessive sur le système
de santé
quand le ministre de la santé dit bon
c'est peut-être la dernière vague est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est un peu
optimiste et qu'il faut plutôt
s'attendre à avoir comme ça d'autres
variant qui risque d'arriver et lofo
s'habituer à vivre avec
avec ce virus à ses d'expression
maladroite bien évidemment parce que
scientifiquement rien ne laisse rien ne
supporte le fait rien ne vient appuyer
le fait scientifiquement parlant que ce
serait la dernière vague par contre et
c'est là où je parle de maladresse par
contre je pense que ce que voulait dire
le ministre sait que c'est peut-être
le tournant de la pandémie dans le sens
où
on aurait mis fin à la pandémie pandémie
veut dire que le virus circule en même
temps dans tous les pays de la planète
et donc c'est cette étape là qui
pourrait être terminée en 2022
le virus ne disparaissant pas de la
terre mais grâce à l'immunité engendrés
par omicron et bien après omicron on se
retrouverait avec des foyers
épidémiques dans certains pays mais pas
en même temps et on ne serait plus en
phase pandémique ça c'est quelque chose
de probables je pense que c'est ce que
voulait dire le ministre en disant que
c'était la dernière vague alors au delà
de la crise à laquelle vous faites face
d'ailleurs en tant que médecin mais il
ya aussi tout ce qu'on a appris de cette
crise sanitaire il ya d'abord la
situation de l'hôpital vous même vous
avez été conseillé à 2000 mise de de la
santé
est-ce que
est ce que cette crise sanitaire risque
de nous faire changer notre regard au
fond sur les priorités en matière de
santé en tout cas il le faudrait ce que
l'on peut dire c'est que si on se
souvient
mais joindre 2020 après la première
vague il y as a été le discours un
discours assez consensuel est assez
général ou là là on a compris et on a
compris qu'il était temps de moderniser
le système de santé en particulier en
france parce que c'est un système de
santé qui était basée sur la notion
qu'il n'y aurait plus jamais en europe
et en france en particulier
d'épidémie ou de maladies infectieuses
tout va entraîner un tel problème au
sein de la société on était convaincu
qu'il fallait organiser le système de
santé pour traiter cancer pour traiter
les maladies neurodégénératives
et que l'on n'avait pas à se soucier et
comme avait plus à se préoccuper de ce
type de menace donc ça il faut
impérativement que l'on que l'on modifie
les choses qu'on reprenne ce discours
parce que il est clair que nous devons
tout faire pour renforcer la part de
l'organisation du système de santé
consacrée à la prévention c'est à la
fois et ça nécessite plusieurs actions
importantes ça nécessite d'abord un
investissement massif dans la prévention
plutôt que dans les structures de soins
ensuite ça nécessite de modifier
considérablement la formation des futurs
soignants mois et dans ma formation et
dans ma faculté dans la formation des
jeunes professionnels la part de la
prévention est extrêmement modeste par
rapport à la part du traitement des
maladies établi ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut profondément changé et
repenser considérablement l'organisation
notre système de santé et la formation
des soignants et ça ça prend du temps
bien sûr absolument ça prend du temps
informations aux désirs
rajoutons des médecins s'amenant la
formation ses 11
absolument et puis en plus la question
n'est pas de mon point de vue numérique
elle n'est pas au nombre
est aujourd'hui on a formé on forme des
médecins et des infirmières et des
kinésithérapeutes vraiment en nombre
très insuffisant par contre c'est leur
distribution
l'organisation encore une fois de
l'offre de l'offre de soin qui est
aujourd'hui inapproprié aux
problématiques de santé de notre société
et de celles qui vont venir dans les
prochaines dans les prochaines années
pour ses - le nombre de soignants
informé que l'exercice de leur métier
la façon dont ils exercent et dont on
nous exerçons notre métier et l'éco
système dans lequel nous exerçons notre
métier la deuxième leçon qu'on a appris
le fond de cette crise c'est la
formidable intelligence et créativité
des chercheurs avec cet arn messager qui
est arrivé alors qu'ils étaient
recherchés depuis quelques années mais
enfin c'est l'élève voit la rapidité
avec laquelle on a trouvé une réponse
quand même et ça c'est absolument
admirable quand même absolument et ça
pour moi ce qu'on a ce que le grand
public a découvert ce qui a été mis en
lumière ici c'est vraiment la notion de
science sans frontières c'est à dire que
face à un problème de l'humanité
l'ensemble des scientifiques à la fois
du monde académique mais aussi du monde
industriel des structures privées se
sont alliées d'ailleurs une cause
commune avec un partage inédit de donner
à partage inédit d une mutualisation
inédite de moyens et des investissements
considérables et tout ça a fait que
cette alliance du monde scientifique
pour lutter contre l'ennemi qu'était le
virus a permis ces avancées absolument
inédite c'est incroyable que en deux ans
à peine on ait réussi à développer non
pas un vaccin mais plusieurs axes à deux
technologies différentes
et qu'on ait pu développer des
médicaments
dirigée contre la maladie et contre les
différentes étapes de la maladie c'est
vraiment inédit ça ne s'est jamais
produit avant en médecine même pour le
sida le sida ça a pris de dix ans de
d'engagement pour développer les
premières thérapeutique ici en deux mois
on a développé tout un arsenal de 13 en
deux ans ça veut dire que vos faux je
vais le regarder du médecin que vous
êtes sur cette année 2022 on peut être
relativement optimiste au fond malgré
malgré les difficultés il faut être
optimiste parce que encore une fois on a
sur le plan médical et sanitaire on a
toutes les raisons de l'être
au connais très bien je ne dis pas que
ça va être la fin de la pandémie de
l'épidémie ce qui est certain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on connaît très bien la
maladie on est capable de prendre en
charge les patients des coups pas
capables de prévenir donc il y a du
point de vue du contrôle de lakovic 19
on est dans une situation où l'on peut
être sera on a beaucoup comme vous
l'avez dit appris à la fois sur nous sur
nos systèmes sur notre société sur
l'organisation d'un système de santé et
je suis convaincu que les efforts
collectifs vont être faits pour que pour
donner un nouvel élan à
la santé au système de santé en france
renforçant encore sa base puisqu'il est
fondé sur la solidarité
merci beaucoup pour un cervidé diane
année et veut et bonne année
bonne année également merci beaucoup